Okay, so here's your chance to demonstrate what you've learned
thus far. You know, my computer science professor in college
used to say, if you truly want to learn something,
teach it to someone else. And that's what we are doing
to do in this exercise. We want you to find
a friend or a colleague that does not know much
about computer programming at all. And then we want you
to teach this program that we've written together to that individual.
Now, while you're doing that, we want you to use
your phone or a video camera to record a video of
your conversation with that friend. Capture their reactions and then
you can share that video with us on our discussion forum.
Now, if you don't have access to a video camera,
you can also share with us photos or some text describing
your friend's reaction while you were teaching them this piece of
code. The next video we'll showcase how to share videos and
photos on our discussion forum.